if you remember when we were talking
about how we're thinking about topics
especially in the lead up to
next assessment um we did we covered
motion
before so displacement velocity
acceleration the basics of it
now we spent that really brief time on
exponential growth and decay
right so i hope that after we got all
the weird terminology like growth rates
and
kind of thing out of the way it was
quite simple like it's just
you differentiate and then you stick
stuff in or you integrate
it's not that much different from what
you've already been doing
now we're coming back to fashion so this
is the this is the three unit part
of motion uh hopefully today um you'll
gain a
an appreciation for why this is three
unit motion that there actually
is um it's not just like the same stuff
and more of it
you actually have to make some
conceptual leaps and some thinking which
is a little more
uh rigorous and difficult than what we
had to do under two unit which is kind
of just
okay differentiate here's some cool
equations and then
you just put numbers into it this
requires a bit more thought okay
so let's revise we started with
our equations of motion right and we
called displacement
x so we'd say usually x
is some function of time right
and then because we're thinking calculus
right we think about how displacement
changes
so we call that x dot right but the
normal word we use for it is velocity
right
so we'd say v is equal to
how your displacement is changing right
so that's dx on dt
you know distance over time kilometers
per hour
meters per second that kind of thing
should make my dot a bit clearer
all right and then we went one more
further step we said you differentiate
again
okay what you're going to get is
how velocity is changing right which you
could think of in two ways
um you can think of that as acceleration
right
or if you're more physically you can
think of it as a force
it's the same idea right something
that's acting upon something else and
making its velocity change
and we said well look you want to take
your velocity and see how that is
changing over time
um and since velocity itself is also a
derivative
getting acceleration or the force is
just taking the second derivative
okay now that's that's our revision and
the important thing you want to get is
that all of these
what they have in common is that they're
all functions of time
they're all telling us characteristics
about the motion of an object
um in terms of when right do you know
have you got some equations that govern
where something is at a particular time
and then you can
sort out the rest of it okay but
uh you remember this topic is actually
not called three in a motion does anyone
remember what its
real name is it's a bit long but awkward
it's called this is probably worth
writing down since we're sort of um
we're starting this right two unit
motion is displacement velocity and
acceleration which is what we just
looked at okay but three in a motion is
um sorry i think it's applications
of calculus
to the physical world
okay so that's that's why there's so
much like oh this feels like physics you
know
forces and that kind of thing now here's
the reason why i'm drawing attention to
the name and why it's actually a really
good name even if it's a bit of a
mouthful
in reality we usually well a lot of the
time
we don't know things about motion
characteristics of version
in terms of time okay far more
frequently
we know them in terms of displacement
okay so
instead of knowing uh things about an
object and how it's moving
based on when it is what time it is we
know them based on
where it is okay so examples you know
you've got two objects
okay with different masses
okay we say that these two objects
attract each other everywhere
all the time right but how much is their
attraction
governed by their motion toward each
other right this
sort of force here which we call
gravity right it's not so much about
time how do we usually express it
does anyone know the equation for
gravitational attraction
i think it's something like you've got
to take the product sorry
the product of the masses right so the
more massive your objects are the more
they're going to attract each other
and then you divide by do you remember
anyone
yeah the square of the radius right in
terms of like what that distance is
right so the further things are apart
the more this denominator is getting
bigger okay so the further things are
apart
the less things are acting upon each
other and the heavier they are
the more they're acting on each other
right so you can see here right gravity
obviously makes things move makes things
orbit and so on
but it has nothing to do with time at
least not in the way that we usually
think about it it's more about how close
you are to something or how far you are
and most forces are like that like
magnetism all the different forces of
nature they sort of you know that's the
way they work
so how can we express any of these well
obviously i mean
displacement is not really there's not
much use expressing displacement in
terms of displacement so
we'll leave that one behind but how can
we get velocity and acceleration
in terms of displacement so instead of
dts here instead of differentiating with
respect to t
we want things on on dx right
okay we want to see if we can express
velocity and acceleration
as functions of displacement
differential
equations okay